but tonight i sit down with the
klitschko brothers and it was one of the
most
heart-rending and powerful interviews i
think i've ever done
vladimir vitale thank you so much to
both of you for seeing me today it's a
great honor to come to kiev in ukraine
and to see you both here
how tough
have the last few months been for both
of you
right now already 150 days
i have a feeling
it's one
long long long day
non-stop
challenges
the
rescue
help to the people
savings alive
take me back to the day that russia
invaded
did you think either of you that this
would happen
definitely we have information from
from some services is happen the
russians prepare
but we
hope
it's not happens
we can't realize
it's
it's possible
it's actually
doesn't accept
normal
uh
it's nobody can tell in modern time
it's possible
to kill the people in value
what is of
the price of for human lives
it's nothing
what's extraordinary but i mean is
when you come to kiev today it seems
like a perfectly normal
european democratic city with people
going about their life and yet just a
few months ago
the russians were trying to get into
kiev
and
take it
do you remember that those first few
days
i first of all i want to say thank you
mr morgan that you came here
because
um not everyone
makes this decision understanding you
have to take account that
um
that might be your last trip
you are not safe
when you are on the ukrainian soil
due to russian invasion
even though
they are in the south and the east
russian military forces and the fights
are going on
but just recently
like yesterday
we could hear
the sounds
of artillery explosions
see the death see the destruction
see buildings residential buildings
residential buildings on fire
civilians children
teenagers
tortured death
they've been on the ground for at least
10 days you could you could see it those
bodies were
laying there for a long time
and
it's just something that
cannot possibly
be accepted in in your mind because um
speaking of myself
i never been the war i never saw
so
so many dead people at
once and then
it just
it just um
makes you feel you are having a bad
dream when your dream takes a long time
even though
as my brother just said it's like one
one very long day
because there's like so many things are
happening and um
and having current life in a city that
seems like
like normal yeah ish
so normally you cannot call because you
see the barricades and you see that um
more military presence and you see the
certain energy in the vibe yes and
people
and just recently the city was empty the
city that was filled up with five
million people before the war
all of a sudden was
empty in march beginning of march
empty no cars no people no life and
three weeks ago
vitaly
key was attacked again with long-range
missiles fired by the russians at the
city
this could happen at any moment i
presume
nobody's safe in
no safety feeling for anyone in
ukrainian territory
any second any minute
russian records can launch it in any
buildings and kill everyone
no guarantee
and
that why
is risky
but
we
talking about that many times we see how
many civilians has died as deaths in in
killed
in this period of time and uh russian
explanation is special operation against
military forces is liar
we know it's just in our
city destroyed more than 600 buildings
220 apartment buildings
we know
its whole city moreover destroyed
[Music]
another city is totally destroyed
you i know you went to butcher but i
mean didn't you both of us you both went
yeah and the scenes that you found in
busha were
horrifying it just
it cannot anyhow
possibly
um your mind cannot really kind of you
know work through this because it's just
unhuman for those who've never been in a
war what did you see what did you see in
in
i i can tell you those images are
horrifying
you see flattened car
and with silent children
flattered you see bodies in that car
flooding by the tank
you see
people that were
on their knee with hands
tied behind their back teenagers
teenagers i don't know how young they
were
shot in the head executed
you see bodies
all over the place between the houses on
the streets
uh in underground to the houses
everywhere
it's just like
enormous amount of
death that was silent
but it's also
shocking with the destruction that um
that was all around all around the city
of kiev vitoria that's it uh i want to
tell you
exactly what uh tell right now vladimir
it's this war
has sends from russian side
they need ukrainian territory
but they don't need the population
ukrainian population they don't care how
many they kill and
they want to kill everyone
they want to occupy territory
and they want to kill the people
i'm guilty of
it's
children woman's
we wasn't butchered so i never forget
the
this images is street with bodies
old woman
grandma 70 years
more than 70 years old
she
killed
children teenager what kind of people do
this
no explanation and just one explanation
it's not the
it's not the war it's genocide yes
and i believe that uh it's clearly
understandable why these wars go on the
way it's going
um i think it's
certain rewriting the history whatever
the history is
rewriting
the history that um the capital of
entire
former russia and all the
countries together
with starting keith's careers with
thousand five hundred years of history
of this city
um and we're writing that
it's not russia won the second world war
but soviet union with allies is england
and the united states
and it's just in certain ways rewriting
that
this is our territory that's how
russians call our crim crimea peninsula
crimea this is our territory but what
does it mean hour i mean literally they
need
ukraine but not the ukrainians and you
could tell that we just like in the way
of uh of the truth
and now it's obvious the longer this war
is going the more clear is going to be
for the world
that is so
insane to do something in 2022 insane
because i would say in a certain way you
possibly could rewrite the history if it
was like 100 years ago you cannot do it
right now this certain way it's a
blockchain thankfully to globalization
you cannot just delete and erase the
history in one part because it's always
going to pop up
too much has been
noted
too much has been seen
and also learned even though the free
world is still making mistakes in my
opinion just letting russia do what
they've done before
because there's complete dependence
on energy and that's why
silence
stepping back malaysian flight was shot
okay maybe later on we will
exactly see how that happens where the
rocket came from
um an annexation of peninsula crimea
that's all right with the rest um
lugansk and donetsk that's all right so
it's been coming but no consequences
sanctions
verbally
consequences
if russia will invade ukraine verbally
in the beginning
i mean i had a feeling the free world
was just watching and observing like
okay three days that's what
did
the buzz is out there the three days in
ukraine is gonna fail there will be
people watching this who maybe only know
you two
from your boxing careers you were two
world heavyweight champions uniquely
these fighting brothers who conquered
the world vitali you never got knocked
down in your entire professional career
you're now facing both of you the fight
of your life you're the mayor of kiev
this capital city the russians have
already tried to attack you once i'm
sure they'll probably try again you've
been
actually fighting with the reservists
here
is this the biggest fight of your lives
for both of you
i would say you know i'm not gonna put
it i wouldn't put it on on the
so speak blanket you know on on us it's
um it's us in this case ukrainians yeah
we we all do
um someone in the front
literally right now and
someone gave up their life and
there are different fronts there are
many fronts
and to run the city
during this
war times i don't want to say
challenging times war times
uh it is it is complicated as well as
everything else in the country and it's
us
and it's us not to forget not just us
ukrainians
us
europeans us
so-called free world
us against the evil evil decision to
invade
ukraine not just invade
with new technologies
and uh invade for creation but
destruction
that was done on 22nd of uh 24th of
february but vitaly that that day they
invaded uh and over the next few days
i know that you were struck by the fact
that ukrainian people rather than all
wanting to run away the men
came to you
older men in the street and asked you
give me a gun let me fight for my
country i found that very powerful
yeah it's uh
i'm very proud to be ukrainian because
uh the russians attack destroy the
cities and they expect the people will
be in panic they will people will be
depressed instead then
the people angry
and will
have a huge will to defend our city
our homes our families and democrat and
democracy and freedom right i mean it's
wider than just ukraine you're fighting
as a country for your own
life but you're fighting for global
democracy the reason of this senseless
war is everyone have to clearly
understand
the reason
of
invasion to ukraine to occupy ukraine
our wish
to be
the part of european family to build
modern european country
the russians never accept our wish and
putin wants to rebuild russian and
soviet empire
everyone have to clearly understand them
the reason of this senseless war
and
we
was in ussr and we see our future
as part of european family as democratic
free country ukraine and we fighting
right now for the future for our country
for our children
we don't want to live in the country
with no human rights no pressure freedom
no democratic values ways dictator outer
terrorism
we was in ussr and we don't want back to
your ssr point
when you were younger your father was a
communist he was also a soviet uh pilot
and he he loved leonard rashnef the the
leader of the soviets at the time
of course and i know that when when he
died you said that you cried for weeks
when
the inauguration had died
because your family was so brought up to
believe
this man was
was
so magnificent but then an interesting
thing happened i think batarli for you
where
you went to america in your late teens
and you discovered that all the
propaganda about america and the west
wasn't what you found
tell me about that
uh we grown up in soviet union and
propaganda worked so so much every uh in
every uh in in the school we have every
week couple of lessons about the
political lessons we call that political
lessons were explained about
bad united states
bad
[Applause]
europe for
bad
the system and
what they want to do it with us they
want the americans
their
whole world to want to attack us and
want to make the slaves
from every one of us and we truly
believe that from
from child
we
the system make brainwashing for every
one of us and yes of course i was small
child brethren died and
depression was symbol of our country and
uh i i small i was nine years old and i
i think is is it is it
nobody protects us anymore and right now
the american scam i i was
shocked and not just me
millions of people in russia because we
was zombed from propaganda right now the
exactly the same way well i'm going to
come to the parallel with now but when
you went to america i think you were 18
what did you discover
thanks peter historically came and they
have a chance at sportsmen a sportsman
to fly to the united states i was 18
years old
i was really surprised every everything
is
is a liar
i came back to to ukraine
i talked to our father father was
communist he truly believed in this
system and told father
everything what what what we listen it's
stories these good people is good gas
friendly people it's a good country it's
they have
so many products they have
uh
100 types of cha of cheese
for us it's there yes of course there's
something we have just one cheese
the one
[Music]
you know what is we have we grown up in
in system where
we doesn't have doesn't have so much uh
choice and
did your father believe you and
father father told
listen
the americans
make one beautiful city
especially to make a propaganda it's
everyone come and see how beautiful
america america is horrible
please
don't
pay attention for that they try to use
you personally as as
propaganda instrument because you
explained to everyone the americas uh
and then beautiful then you took your
father to america uh many many years
later
i had a chance
we have actually
working with hbo in united states boxing
there i bring my father we bring our
father to the united states and uh
remind him are you remember we're
talking about that father
sorry guys i don't
i don't i don't uh
expect
uh expect uh
if we actually
everyone was uh
from
the system but he was a victim your
father in a way of the propaganda
machine and now we see the same
propaganda
in russia with putin 70 of russians
genuinely believe he is fighting a just
war against nazis and fascists in
ukraine you know oppressing russian
speaking people who must be saved it's
the same kind of mentality brainwashing
the people to believe a complete lie i
believe back in soviet times it was
easier to hide the truth now it's more
complicated due to globalism and
internet and different sources where
people can get through information and
make their own choice and it is
it is complicated and complex but we've
seen that
for over a decade um the system for
propaganda in russia was well prepared
and worked well not just in russia but
not to forget also in the rest of the
world because
russian-sponsored
state-sponsored media
is still is still even now
um transmitting the messages the news
in switzerland for instance i was in
shock when we were in davos on davos
economic conference where i was at the
hotel and turned on tv and i see city of
mariopo
explained by the russian
media
state-sponsored media that ukrainians
destroyed the city so you know sick and
sick life
it's
it is it is and um
even though
they've been successful with that but
it will end up not well for russia and
russian propaganda you cannot hide the
truth for too long you can't
and it's just a matter of time i just
wish this time is going to
not last for too long so not too many
too much of destruction is going to be
done not too many people going to be
taken but vitali um
you're a major target for the russians
and they were trying to find you and
kill you early on
we know from your sporting career as a
heavyweight champion you don't stand
back you don't fear other human beings
but was there a moment
in the early days where you feared for
your life and do you still fear for your
life listen
everyone
every ukrainian
ukrainians was targeted
every
one
who
support ukraine
who support
the
the our wish to be the european
uh country
who want to build democracy is a target
was the target and still the target of
russians
you sent your family away your wife and
your three children they've gone away to
another part of a safer part of the
country
yeah we send the rest of our family to
safe
place when did you last see them
a long time ago six months ago you
haven't seen your family for six months
yeah thank you to for technology we make
video conference we're talking every day
but you have three children you haven't
been able to hug during a war right i
mean that's tough yeah it's tough but a
big part of my family is here
watching my back yeah i mean if he needs
a hug i'm giving him
that's fine or the other way around but
it must be nice for you to have each
other because you've always had each
other but now i would imagine more than
ever particularly if you're separated
from family members other family members
it is and probably i probably will
speaking of
continuing with
exploring like questions like
um
are you ready to die for your country
yeah this question was asked and they
probably like sense it that something is
coming they're like that's your country
that's your home your principles and
everything and uh
and you know that's the simplest thing
you can do
die for a country you know what's most
complicated live for your country that
means fight yeah for life
protect your people protect your country
protect yourself it's so complicated and
at some point
you're really kind of feeling like you
know what i'm gonna run into my death so
to speak just to end up this misery but
no
the strength is of us ukrainians that
also
we don't want to die even though a lot
of
being already killed and tortured and
raped
and now still
putting life on the line but living for
your country is more complicated more
challenging
and it's definitely
something that we don't want to do as
ukrainians
run into our death
so we stay strong we stay alive
we fight for our choice not to live on
our knee
have you been both have you lost
friends or family members in this war
yourselves
thanks god we didn't lose lost the
family members but a lot of friends
already have been killed i was killed
you see we can't imagine it you know
living in london
we have the odd terrorist attack or
whatever but we can't imagine a war of
the kind we had in world war ii where
the german bombers were coming over and
blitzing our homes that hasn't happened
in the uk for 70 plus years
to see it happen in a democratic
european country like ukraine is it's
just surreal and to hear you say you've
lost
a number of friends already the wall's
only been going a few months and already
it's impacting you personally in a way
that is everyone in ukraine i guess i
have some message to great britain for
everyone
outside of the country to europe for
europe all the world
if someone
seeing the war some far away
from you
somewhere in ukraine and this war
doesn't touch him personally his biggest
mistake
this war
can touch everyone in european continent
ukraine one of the largest country in
europe
and instability in ukraine can bring
instability in the whole region
and
please don't forget ukraine have five
nuclear plants one of them one of the
biggest uh largest
nuclear plants in ukraine was on fire
it will be explosions be strategy much
bigger times bigger than
than chernobyl catastrophe
in this case
this war
can touch personally everyone in the
planet
what's been extraordinary has been the
reaction from so many people around the
world to
ukraine and ukrainian people and the
courage and the fortitude
that you've been showing you have a jar
of pennies there vitaly just on the desk
if you could just reach over and grab
that for me because i
wanted you to to just explain what this
child
listen it's one of the stories very
tasteful story
our
sister city
riga sent the buses to give to help and
the merit
mayor of riyadh told to everyone the bus
is empty let's bring some stuff to
ukrainian
to ukrainian people to help them people
bring some
sweatshirts uh food medication
uh and one small boy around six years
old
uh
bring the this glass full with the
there with the
small money
and give
the money to
mayor of riga
and
say i collect this money life long it's
life savings live stage six
and i want to give this money to
ukrainian children
i give hundred dollars to the foundation
but i want to give this money back to
this boy when the war finished
small boy
with big heart yes it's a wonderful
story there's another story you tell
which has a much sadder ending you met a
young boy same age at the station soon
after the invasion
and he was crying for his mummy and
daddy and you were trying to console him
and then a woman came up to you and said
actually
both his parents are dead and we just
haven't been able to tell him yet that's
got to be a gut wrenching moment yeah
it's
very attached to
it was
second third week of the war
it's our train station was full the
people
we try to equate people much safety
place in ukraine
and
breaking fall in one corner
we
make for the children
with the toys
and children play there some small
playground
and
i'm visiting checking everything is fine
and see the small boy crying there
come to him
keep five don't worry everything is good
ask uh mom
dad and
don't worry any minutes you parents come
in here
and one more woman come to me
and where yeah
not so loud tell me
sorry
this child is this child don't know
he's alone
the parents was killed
and we are
not allowed
to tell your truth
how did that make you feel that moment
as a father are you getting angry
angry and i understand everyone
everyone who want the people ask me in
the street
the people ask me
mr mayor
give to other weapons we're ready to
fight
and defending our children
defending our homes i mean it's
complicated i would imagine for you
about your feelings towards
russian people
because you have russian blood both of
you you grew up speaking russian and do
you hate the russian people or is your
focus of anger towards putin and the
regime
i was brainwashed i didn't understand
what was going on
i really believed
they were nazis and don't forget the
reasons have been changed first
demonstration
special operation the fight against nato
it's our land
we historically rewrite it because it's
our land so there are always some new
excuses because none of them worked from
the beginning
is putin for you is he the new hitler
people use that phrase a lot but in his
case
given what he's done
given the way hitler invaded poland and
the way putin's invaded ukraine i
believe nazi germany and what russia is
doing in ukraine with filtration camps
with destruction
with destruction of life and
infrastructure and anything living in
ukraine there are parallels with nazi
germany there are parallels yeah i
completely agree
should the west be doing more than it's
currently doing not just providing
military but some people think that nato
the greatest military force in history
should actually
attack putin it was mistake to be able
to take natural status
and first point second point
we have to be strong
the russians
accepted just strong position
they
doesn't pay attention to weak people
weak politicians weak
decisions and regarding questions
the west have to do it more yes
first point second point
west right now is too slowly
long discussion about
defensive weapon i want to tell
defensive weapon because we defend our
country
we need the help
uh
north stream too long long discussion
about that that but definitely take
decision it's too slow has europe been
too naive
in allowing itself to become too reliant
on russia and putin for its energy
resource has it allowed putin now
to use that as a blackmail weapon
russians use any
leverage
to
make us
weak and they stronger
what is your what is it
it's fascinating to me that you grew up
in a in a family where communism was
king that was the belief everybody
believed it strongly
and then the wall came off your eyes in
a way and you saw the reality by going
to america
and realized a lot of it was lies and
propaganda if russian people are
watching this interview
what's your direct message to them
it's
i try to
i speak with many russians
very intelligent
people
good educated
but they truly believe in russian
government
exactly the same question i gave me in
second world war how
so huge population germany with a
big cultural plus with some so many with
intelligence
intelligence people uh
make it
getting crazy in very short period of
time somebody i think it was goebbels
the propaganda
architect of nazis
who said it's easy to get the people to
do what you want you just have to make
them scared
that's the point and that's exactly and
that was joseph gilbert exactly with
fear and being scared and it's not just
about the russian people what are you
going to say to russian people right now
they're not going to listen to it right
then they're going to watch it because
they believe understand it because it's
in english yeah it's not going to be
translated forget about it
but it's all fear it's more to the free
world
say more than the to the russians they
are victims of the situation and they
scare to death yeah to say anything
against the will of their government
so is in a certain way in the western
world
being
afraid scared or
coward
i think a lot of the world is also i
think all putin's had to do is say if
you do anything
i'll use my nuclear weapons and it seems
to me the west has gone oh no no no we
can't we better be careful
we can't and once putin knows
that the west has backed off because of
that threat why would he stop using that
threat he'll keep using that threat you
know we have we have as the former
fighters we have a good saying which
applies to everything because
who is holding the weapons a human there
is not a human on other side
weapons meaning uh economical side with
gas and oil or or nuclear weapons or any
other they're human
so
bully the bully
that's the saying we have in boxing you
have an opponent
wearing the gloves
and if you're going to let him do
whatever he wants to do he is really
going to do whatever he wants to do
what's the matter with the mike tyson
quote everyone has a plan everyone has a
plan until he gets hit exactly right and
and that's it's pretty much applying
under parallels you have to bully the
bully if you always let to take step
back
you just make the pull is stronger and
that's exactly what must be taken
consequences hard consequences for every
action should be reaction
equal how often do you talk to each
other
every day
once a day more more uh i didn't count
did you
not everybody
i mean listen you have a remarkably
close relationship i have two brothers
um i don't talk to them every day but
has your relationship become closer
because of this war has it brought you
even closer than you were
no no
war it doesn't
play any role in
always from beginning
the two of the parents go to work and i
have to care about uh my small brother
and uh i care about him until today
and uh
take responsibility and also right now
he's so big enough to take
responsibility uh and your mother your
brother your mother always said she
never wanted to see you fight against
each other but nowadays you don't say
she said there was family propaganda
don't fight each other
support each other did you ever fight
like quietly have you ever had that
little
no no no i was smart enough to realize
as a five year younger
he was 15 i was 10. what's the chances
so i was waiting and waiting for how
many female tips right now right now is
uh right now it's a good idea to fight
younger brother he's too strong enough
he looks
your guns are pretty pumped there
so
you reckon you take him now if you
finally
there's there's no reason i mean what is
the reason
just you know sibling rivalry
you know there is no rivalry there's
competition healthy competition uh and
more of a support english advert you
both look very fit but uh vitali means
you work out every day
does it help with the
the mental pressures that you must be
feeling healthy body healthy spirit
healthy mind
what do you both when you think about
the war ending and it will end it we
don't know when i hope it ends very soon
but when it ends
what's the thing you're both most
looking forward to when when that day
comes when freedom comes
as mayor of kiev we have a lot of plans
to change our city i enjoy my job
because it's huge responsible but i
change by myself my hometown my country
and i enjoy that to see the result and
people very appreciate to see new
schools new preschools new street new
parks and they enjoy that and
i
enjoy that also if people happy
to make people happy is
is great privilege
our plans to be successful
it's best answer for our friends
and also for our enemy
be successful and success of the country
is a main priority frank sinatra in fact
mike tyson actually has a poster of
frank sinatra in his office in los
angeles he showed me
and it's sinatra's quote the best
revenge
is great success
yep that's true that seems to me what
you're saying what about for you
vladimir what do you most look forward
to when this is when this is over
i'll be very honest obviously family and
all the personal stuff which shouldn't
be public but
i would say that
this war showed as well as 30 years of
being
an athlete that focused agility
coordination and endurance are important
principles in family life in sport
in politics and also in the war these
qualities we ukrainians have and we
ukrainians showing face to the challenge
and we the free world will stand
together with ukraine against this
aggression and show that the good will
always conquer the evil
thank you both so much for your time uh
it's been a great honor to come to kyiv
and to see you both together you're you
know the the world looks on with huge
admiration you're very inspiring like so
many ukrainians and
we're all behind you all decent people
are behind you
and you should know that
and please
not only verbally but
with everything
else that already been done but please
more we need it now
more we need the support so so so much
thank you for being here because
we're fighting and defending not just
our families not our children
we're defending the same walls what we
have yeah we're fighting for every one
of you
you know what you're fighting for
freedom and democracy which are the most
important things in the world
and that doesn't just stay in ukraine
that applies everywhere and it was the
same in 1939 it's the same now and i
wish you every success
in winning this war i really do so thank
you for your time thank you thank you
you